we've got a full circle last streisand
she also visited the center yes yes that
that was incredible I mean I I think I
held my breath for 10 minutes while she
was there I mean she is lovely and you
know she's just an incredible woman and
that the truth is is throughout her
whole career she really had a hand in
every single detail and I really admire
that about her and when she came on said
she was so lovely and so yeah warm to
all of us and she washed a little bit of
the you know earlier edits of the film
and it was it was spectacular and we've
got a great picture of the two of you
together it's like diva squares oh was
that before that's before before yes
that's the first time you met her right
yeah we have had dinner together at her
house yeah of course you had
the transformation is extraordinary in
here and a bit like keeping the accent
up all the time you did you keep the
teeth in all the time yeah I had his
teeth in because he has a over by a
massive over by which he never wanted to
mess with because he has four octave
range that he said I'm not screwing with
this ball I had these teeth made I was
like you enjoyed it so much I'm not a
method actor I'm a method actor so let's
stop talking down method acts no problem
with it I'm just saying I'm not I've
worked I've worked with method actors
that I absolutely adore and we can go on
about that I'll tell you about this I
cut my teeth in because I never get a
chance to end every sentence with
darling and dear and Freddie does and
that's quite nice it's nice it's nice
being I'd rather be Freddie Mercury for
most of the day than be Rami maja
by that and I appreciate it the director
your Gosselin Thomas I mean actually
killer you've talked on the show about
doing sex scenes and how embarrassing
that can be with with your Goss let the
boss know does he make them less
embarrassing more embarrassing more
awkward otter
he's very even me you have to feel safe
to be able to do those things that you
have to feel secure the director to
trust them and I trust him completely
it was just all quite embarrassing yeah
but you were a special thing to protect
because Emma I think Emma Stone yeah she
was worried about you
yeah well she was so Emirates Damon had
to finger me sort of avoid finding
anything that you shouldn't have because
it's sort of under the sheets like that
and she said a little bit worried about
it don't worry don't worry I'm will I
know I know so I asked makeup Titan if
they had a sponge and so I put a sponge
there
I think the finest sponge it was a big
wet sponge made up this story afterwards
picture just going up my leg and she
would
one of the beautiful women your mother
she's got the plus one for the Oscars oh
yes absolutely first time of course mom
is going and you've just done that lunch
that nominees lunch the Oscar nominee
luncheon is your lunch do you eat yes
you do
oh yes we do and the dessert was
delicious it was the best part of the
lunch but it is actually a really
wonderful event because they're smart to
put only one actor at the table so they
have people from each cat oh you know
well no I actually I missed the lunch I
was working yeah so I missed that the
most fun I've never missed a lunch
we've got the picture they take a
picture whenever they do this they huge
picture of you all you can't even find
me I'm sure oh I did earlier there you
are yeah yeah and I always thought was
just have a bun fight to find a place to
stand but they printed they tell you
where to stand they tell you where to
stand and you know you you stand for the
introduction of every person so we're
there clapping but you've you've been no
didn't even look it's here
but now what the thing is after the
garbage you were talking about you only
been on shows like this talking about a
how you put this mad crush on Sam Elliot
I do and but now he knows so there he is
he's been placed quite far away from
they made sure I wouldn't a costume at
that luncheon so these headshots before
we show them how did these headshots
first of all I don't know how you got
them because I literally thought I had
the only two hard copies I was like dear
God they're out there I had just moved
to LA I had only done theater in New
York for a very long time and I got my
first commercial agent which was like
above us like a sandwich shop so he he
told me that I had to get character
shots and it's usually I always found
them silly because it's like do you
really if you're gonna play a cop do you
really need to see a picture of someone
like in a cop just I've been working at
The Groundlings theater and I was doing
this weird character of this woman who
like gave out cheese samples in a
grocery store and I was like I'll do
Carol two weird characters like no one
is ever going to hire these one who's
that who's the first one the first one
[Laughter]
[Applause]
- job
to the dolphin I am 26 in that picture
and I thought it was a great idea to put
on a gray wig and old lady glasses I'm
like sure who wouldn't hire her hire her
before this next woman that is from
Western Barbie I took her hat and I took
her it's a cowboy hat from what's the
thing about your daughter wanting to
make you cry oh we were talking about
what I do for a living and and I was
explaining how I try to make my I just
make-believe like she does when she
plays and she's like just can you make
yourself laugh and I see that she goes
can you make yourself cry and I said
yeah and she goes to do it obviously you
gotta give me a story so we made up a
story and I've done it before for people
about sriracha I don't want to go back
into this grandma no no okay
what is this sure Asha plant is um
they're shutting it down because the
fumes kind of go into the community and
yeah but I've done this this is
redundant you should be an actress
what you say I believe it was Michael
brought up his chest because your chest
in Black Panther we've got here this
year in Black Panther this this caused a
sensation
there was an orthodontist that came
forward and said about this young woman
who came in yeah orthodontist had a
patient this this this this girl who was
watching Black Panther and I guess
during that scene she had her retainers
in and she clenched her jaws so tight
that she broke her retainers and that
kind of went viral and a buddy of mine
had sent it to me like hey man have you
seen this and I was like no that's wild
how do you even do that
and so I saw I I sent her a DM I was
like hey I'm I'm sorry and I would love
to can I pay for your retainer or
whatever I saw her to pay for it and she
was like no no no I that's why I have
insurance and I she was a very proper
answer I was like okay cool
she said you know if you're ever in the
Bay Area just you know let me know and I
would love to take a picture too and I
said okay cool
[Music]